in my courteous review I briefly
mentioned that I wasn't a fan of Mecca
due to the fact that my slow attention
span makes me allergic to things like
slow plot development and boring
political [ __ ] they include but I
decided to give Full Metal Panic ago
anyway since apparently it wasn't just a
mecha anime but it was a mecha action
high school comedy sci-fi with a little
bit of romance type anime and I need an
inanimate to keep my mind off Buckner
which is a shows you'd totally go watch
right now sorry back on topic film at
cephalic circles around a girl named
army jittery
it looks like a normal school girl in
the outside but it's actually one of a
select group of people called the
whispered which doesn't mean she can
only play three decibels back she mean
she has secret knowledge on quote
unquote black technology which
apparently gives mecca's the ability to
go super saiyan or some stupid logic
like that which should only ever make
sense in anime so to prevent her from
getting into the wrong hands a secret
military organization you've named
themselves mithril which I suppose is a
better name calling your secret
organization GI Joe sends out one of
their child secret agents service case
Sabra to secretly become Kaname
bodyguard and so after that terrorist
attack and mecca's fight and stuff you
know the drill the class where this
anime is pretty solid with Kaname being
well you can say she's a bit
short-tempered
okay very short-tempered
okay so she does get angry a bit but at
least she tries her hardest to stay calm
and then we come to secret agent Boy
Wonder Sasuke Sakura who's complete lack
of common sense makes up the comedy of
this series now I thought there were
certain qualifications you had to have
before becoming a secret agent
like speaking at least 12 different
languages having wide of rare gadgets or
being able to [ __ ] a girl on a speed
boat but not only the search they
possess none of these qualities he seems
to have skipped the first lesson in
being a secret agent since there's
nothing secret of the screen and the he
bloody does okay so he isn't really a
secret agent he's more like a child
soldier but my previous statement still
remains and secret agent sounds cool
there anyway then we get to the other
characters of Tessa a 16 year old school
goes captain of the submarine I know
Kalinin who's every light is pure gold
to me since I imagined it to be Sean
Connery's always coming out of his mouth
and then we get to Garen the bad guy of
the series who works for a terrorist
organization whose main goal is to
pollachi the series never tells us I
assume is to [ __ ] over America or
something since that seems to be the
goal of most terrorist groups nowadays
well I suppose if they really wanted to
do that they could just look at the
current economy and see that don't need
to bother with this black technology
business or the whispered and realize
that or they really need to do to
[ __ ] country up to take our bunch of
mortgages now with this being a mecha
action high school comedy sci-fi with a
little bit of romance type anime it runs
a risk of trying to do too much but
luckily for mater panic doesn't suffer
from being a mecha action high school
comedy sci-fi with a little bit of
romance type anime and does this by
keeping the comedy in action apart from
each other while putting the romance
somewhere in the middle the comedy plays
on a relationship between Sasuke and
Konami and socia is complete inability
to fit in with Society love bringing in
guns to school setting off flash bangs
in classroom doesn't seem to matter
though since the teachers just don't
look like they give a [ __ ] when I was a
school girl my bullets kicked off if the
phone in my pocket did so much as a
cough but so skater bringing knives guns
grenades penis larger machines aids and
all he'll get is a quick talk from the
teachers as slap from Konami well the
comedy is okay I thought the series
episodes were far superior to the comedy
episodes which is why I'm glad there
were more serious episodes I like the
way they focus more on the pilots
themselves and the actual mecca's which
is the biggest poem I have of most mecha
anime and some of the action scenes
could be surprisingly intense so any any
was everything I could have hoped for in
a mecha action high school comedy sci-fi
with a little bit of romance type anime
the animation is actually pretty good
well at least for his time and I can
only thank God that I didn't
crazy with CT effect seeing this anime
came from gonzo off seeing what CG could
do to another maker Adam a they made
they also kept fan so it's pretty
minimal except for maybe a few moments
in the show and you know my opinion of
dubbing is generally good and this anime
was no exception one problem I had with
the series is with the villain Garen
it's not that he was a bad villain it
was just that he wouldn't [ __ ] dies
if he comes back about three times after
supposedly getting killed I mean he took
a bloody headshot before the anime even
started so until the episode word Chuck
Norris himself descends from the sky
with the army of darkness and Percy
stabs him through the heart with a sort
of Excalibur I'm gonna say right now
that he froze over the second raid I
[ __ ] called it no spoilers in the
comments section please
overall Full Metal Panic is a solid
series that I could recommend to most
people it's fun entertaining and I would
actually Tina this may ironically enough
appeal to non mecha fans more since it
doesn't have the epic political stories
are present in most mecha anime if
there's anything I've learned from
watching this and me that you should go
watch Bukka know now I mean what I meant
to say was it's a good all-around anime
that was enjoyable to watch though the
one and he seems in this show that made
me think this show was anything just
better than playing good so for that
reason I give this anime a solid 8 out
of 10 but seriously go watch Bukka now